in the last video you learned about the
sliding windows object detection
algorithm using a consonant but we
thought that it was too slow in this
video you learn how to implement that
algorithm convolutional e let's see what
this means to build up toward the
convolutional implementation of sliding
windows let's first see how you can turn
fully connected layers in your neural
network into convolutional layers we'll
do that first on this slide and then the
next slide we'll use the ideas from this
slide to show you the convolution
implementation so let's say that your
object detection algorithm inputs 14 by
14 by 3 images this is quite small but
just for illustrative purposes and let's
say it then uses five by five filters
and let's say uses 16 of them to map it
from 14 by 14 by 3 to 10 by 10 by 16 and
then does a 2 by 2 max pooling to reduce
it to 5 a 5 by 16 then has a fully
connected layer 2 connected 400 units
then another fully connected layer and
then finally outputs Y using a soft max
unit in order to make the change we'll
need to in a second I'm going to change
this picture a little bit and instead
I'm going to view Y as 4 numbers
corresponding to the cost probabilities
of the four classes that the softmax
units is classifying amongst and the
four classes could be pedestrian car
motorcycle and background or something
else now what I'd like to do is show how
these layers can be turned into
convolutional layers so the confident
with a draw same as before for the first
few layers and now one way of
implementing this next layer this fully
connected layer is to implement this as
a five by five filter and let's use four
hundred five by five filters so if you
take a 5 by 5 by 16 image and convolve
it with a 5 by 5 filter remember a 5 by
5 filter is implemented as 5 by 5
sixteen because our convention is that
the filter looks across all 16 channels
so the 16 and just 16 must match and so
the output will be one by one and if you
have 400 of these 5 by 5 by 16 filters
then the output dimension is going to be
1 by 1 by 400 and so rather than viewing
these 400 as just a set of notes we're
going to view this as a 1 by 1 by 400
volume and mathematically this is the
same as a fully connected layer because
each of these 400 notes has a filter of
dimension 5 by 5 by 16 and so each of
those 400 values is some you know
arbitrary linear function of these 5 by
5 by 16 activations from the previous
layer next to implement the next
convolutional layer we're going to
implement a 1 by 1 convolution and if
you have 400 1 by 1 filters then with
400 filters the next layer will again be
1 by 1 by 400 so that gives you this
next fully connected layer and then
finally we're going to have another one
by one filter followed by a softmax
activation so as to give a 1 by 1 by 4
volume to take the place of these four
numbers that the network was outputting
so this shows how you can take these
fully connect two layers and implement
them using convolutional layers so that
these sets of units instead are now
implemented as one by one by 400 and one
by one by four volumes armed of this
conversion let's see how you can have a
convolutional implementation of sliding
windows object detection and
presentation on the slide is based on
the over feet paper reference at the
bottom by piercer meet David Egan Xia
Jiang micro Matthew Ron Ferguson Oakland
let's say that your sliding windows
confident inputs 14 by 14 by 3 images
and again I'm just using small numbers
like the 14 by 14 image in this slide
may need to make the numbers and
illustrations simpler so as before you
have a neural network as follows that
eventually outputs a 1 by 1 by 4 volume
which is the output of your softmax unit
and again to simplify the drawing here
14 by 14 by 3 is technically a volume 5
by 5 or 10 by 10 by 16 a second clear
volume but to simplify the drawing for
this slide I'm just only draw the front
face of these volumes so instead of
drawing you know 1 by 1 by 400 volume
I'm just only draw the 1 by 1 parts of
all of these right so just drop the 3d
component of these drawings just for
this slide so let's say that you're
confident inputs 14 by 14 images or 14
by 14 by 3 images and your test set
image is 16 by 16 by 3 so now added that
yellow stripe to the border of this
image so in the original sliding windows
algorithm you might want to input the
blue region into a confident and run
that once to generate a classification 0
1 and then slide it down a bit let's use
the stride of 2 pixels and and then you
might slide oh and then you might slide
that to the right by 2 pixels to input
this green rectangle into the confident
and rerun the whole continent and get
another label 0 1 and then you might
input this orange region into the
confident and run it one more time to
get another label and then do the fourth
and final time with this your lower
right now purple square and
to run sliding windows on this 16 by 16
by 3 image is pretty small image you run
this confident from above 4 times in
order to forget 4 labels but it turns
out a lot of this computation done by
these 4 confidence is highly duplicated
so where the convolutional
implementation of sliding windows does
is it allows these 4 forward passes of
the confident to share a lot of
computation specifically here's what you
can do you can take the confidence and
just run it same parameters the same 5
by 5 by filters also 16 5 by 5 filters
and run it and now you can have a 12 by
12 by 16 output volume and then do the
max cool same as before now you have a 6
by 6 by 16 run through your same 400 5.5
filters to get now your 2 by 2 by 40
volume so now instead of a 1 by 1 so now
instead of a 1 by 1 by 400 volume you
have the said a 2 by 2 by 400 volume
Ramnath 301 by 1 filter gives you
another 2 by 2 by 407 one by one by 400
do that one more time and now you're
left with a 2 by 2 by 4 output volume is
that 1 by 1 by 4 and it turns out that
this blue one by one by four subset
gives you the result of running in the
upper left-hand corner 14 by 14 image
this upper right 1 by 1 by 4 volume
gives you the upper right result the
lower left gives you the results of
implementing the content on the lower
left 14 by 14 region and the lower right
1 by 1 by 4 volume gives you the same
result as running the confident on the
lower right 14 by 14 media and if you
step through all the steps of the
calculation let's look at the green
example if you had cropped out just this
region and passed it through the
confident through the confident on top
then the first layers activations would
have been exactly this region
the next layers activation of the mass
cooling would have been exactly this
region and then the next layer the next
layer would have been as follows so what
this process does what this
convolutional inclination does is
instead of forcing you to run for a
propagation on four subsets of the input
image independently instead it combines
all four into one for computation and
shares a lot of the computation in the
regions of the image that are common so
all four of the 14 by 14 patches we saw
here now let's just go through a bigger
example let's say you now want to run
sliding windows on a 28 by 28 by 3 image
it turns out if you run for crop the
same way then you end up with an 8 by 8
by 4 output and this corresponds to
running sliding windows with that 14 by
14 region and that corresponds to
running sliding windows first on that
region does giving you the output
corresponding on the upper left-hand
corner then using Strider two to shift
one window over one window over one
window over and so on and there ain't
position so that gives you this first
row and then as you go down the image as
well that gives you all of these 8 by 8
by 4 outputs and the N is because of the
max pooling of 2 that this corresponds
to running your neural network with a
stride of 2 on the original image
so just to recap to implement sliding
windows previously what you do is you
drop out a region let's say this is on
14 by 14 and run that to your content
and do that for the next region over
then do that for the next 14 by 14
region then the next one then the next
one the next one the next one and so on
until hopefully that one recognizes the
car but now instead of doing it
sequentially with this convolutional
implementation that you saw in the
previous slide you can implement the
entire image or maybe twenty by twenty
eight and convolutional 'i make all the
predictions at the same time by one for
pass through this big confident in
we have it recognize the position of the
car so that's how you implement sliding
windows convolutional v and it makes the
whole thing much more efficient now this
algorithm store has one weakness which
is the position of the bounding boxes is
not going to be too accurate in the next
video let's see how you can fix that
problem